where do we start when it comes to
fighting what's the first move we do the
most important move in a fight for MMA
for MMA or boxing it really MMA is a jab
especially with Florence gloves on Brian
what are you going to do when I'm
jabbing all night here most importantly
everything starts from a job so I'm here
just jabbing shoving your eyes very
slowly
hit that big old nose yeah right in the
beak yeah right in the beach
yeah so so how do you defend this I'm
just here all night well it's funny
because I have a very good defense I'd
love to see I don't I don't stand here
like a punching bag because you're not
an idiot so as you're throwing your Jab
what I'm going to do is instead of
standing here like a lot of guys I'm
going to fall right to my knees he's
going to say what is he praying and
asking me something I'm going to go and
I'm going to punch him in his baby bird
and that's the end of the fight thanks
gentlemen